The biggest movies of last year had some pretty
amazing moments, and we've devoured hours
of blockbuster excellence in order to experience
the best.
Here are some of the most epic movie moments
from 2018 that are either pause-worthy in
order to take it all in, or deserve a rewind
to watch again.
T'Challa's little sister Shuri is an engineering
genius.
So when she shows off all the technical gadgets
she's invented to help her big brother be
the Black Panther, there are definitely a
bunch of moments when you might want to pause
and examine each invention a little more closely.
"Fully automated, like the old American movie
Baba used to watch."
But the most rewind-worthy moment comes toward
the end of the scene when T'Challa is checking
out his new Black Panther suits.
At first, Shuri implores him to give the suit
a kick, and it goes flying.
But as Shuri explains, the suit has absorbed
the kinetic energy left by T'Challa's kick,
and the suit glows purple with its building
strength.
Then, Shuri asks him to attack again.
"Delete that footage."
Shuri and the audience erupt in laughter at
the sight of the great Black Panther leveled
by a suit on a mannequin.
It's a moment that's definitely worth a rewatch.
Watching Avengers: Infinity War, it's hard
to say if anyone really believed that Thanos
was going to succeed in his plot to wipe out
half the population of the universe.
But then he got all six Infinity Stones into
that gauntlet, and, well, everyone knows what
happened next.
"Ohhhh snap."
After the snap, the dusting begins.
First to go is Bucky, followed by Black Panther,
Groot, Scarlet Witch, and Falcon.
Out in space, Mantis, Drax, Star-Lord, and
Doctor Strange dissolve into space-dust.
But the most crushing dusting has got to be
that of Spider-Man, whose pleading with Tony
Stark is absolutely tragic.
"I don't wanna go, I don't wanna go Mr Stark
Please.
I don’t wanna go.
I don’t wanna go."
How many people paused on Parker's heartbreaking
final moments?
We can only guess.
Hopefully we'll find out soon enough if our
favorite Avengers are saved when Avengers:
Endgame hits theaters.
There are a few pretty awesome pause-worthy
moments in Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom,
2018's sequel to 2015's follow-up to the original
Jurassic Park franchise.
This new movie introduced another scary dinosaur
hybrid, the Indoraptor, which, when it's finally
revealed, deserves a good pause just so we
can get a good look at it.
But Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom's most
pause-worthy moment comes around the middle
of the film, when Claire, Owen, and their
gang try to evacuate the remaining dinos before
a volcano eruption kills them all.
But the bigger dinosaurs move more slowly,
and one unlucky Brachiosaurus doesn't make
it off the island.
In the saddest moment of the movie, the poor
guy is engulfed in smoke, and we hear a final,
heart-breaking bellow from the beast before
he collapses inside the cloud of ash.
“(sad dino)”
It deserves a pause just so we can get in
a moment of mourning before moving on to more
action.
For "technically" being a part of the X-Men
franchise, there are surprisingly few X-Men
characters in the first Deadpool movie, a
fact which Deadpool isn't shy about pointing
out.
"It's a big house it’s funny that I only
see the two of you - it’s almost like the
studio couldn't afford another X-Man."
But Deadpool 2 takes it a bit further and
adds a fun cameo.
When Colossus brings a severely injured Wade
back to the X mansion, Wade remarks again
at the lack of X-Men characters willing to
make an appearance in his knock-off X-Men
movie...which is exactly when they appear.
"They can't just dust off one of the famous
X-Men?
How about that putz with the giant pigeon
wings?
What do those do anyway, carry him 3 feet
off the ground and snatch up the nearest muffin
crumb."
The fun gag is worth a pause just so we can
check out who's in the room: Xavier, Beast,
Quicksilver, Cyclops, Storm, and Nightcrawler.
Mission: Impossible - Fallout - The HALO Jump
The latest installment in the Mission: Impossible
franchise features some of the most intense
action sequences in movie history.
The biggest and most talked-about has got
to be the HALO jump star Tom Cruise takes
from a plane flying 25,000 feet in the air.
The details behind what it took to capture
the jump on film are absolutely insane.
Cruise is the first actor to perform such
a stunt, which is saying a lot about his willingness
to capture authenticity.
He and the crew took over 100 jumps to get
the scene just right, while every jump required
at least 20 minutes of oxygen prep.
And since the shot used in the movie happens
at sunset, they only had one chance per day
to actually shoot the scene.
It's pause-worthy just because of how stunning
the whole thing is, and because once you watch
it, you simply have to know how it was done.
Like the first movie, Marvel's Ant-Man and
the Wasp is filled with light-hearted and
hilarious moments that counter the more dire
and serious aspects of the Marvel Universe.
When Luis gets captured by Sonny Burch, he's
given a truth serum and forced to divulge
all he knows about Scott Lang.
But this is Luis, Scott's blunt yet hilarious
best friend, so when he's given a truth serum,
you can bet he's going to tell you everything.
Luis' story goes all the way back to when
he and Scott met in person, complete with
an enormous curly wig, then through his relationships
with Hope.
"And Scotty is like you know what?
My heart is like broken and I’ll probably
never find love again but DAMN if I wanna
kiss you."
The whole scene is definitely the funniest
sequence in the film, one that you'll probably
want to rewatch.
Throughout the Star Wars prequel Solo: A Star
Wars story, Emilia Clarke's Qi'ra and Paul
Bettany's Dryden Vos make references to a
higher criminal organization known as Crimson
Dawn.
During the climax of the film, Qi'ra slays
Dryden, and abandons the love of her life,
Han Solo.
It's at that point that she pledges allegiance
to Crimson Dawn via hologram, and a familiar
face pops up in the holographic communication
device: Darth Maul.
It was a moment that left audience members
collectively gasping… but also asking, "How?"
Casual Star Wars movie viewers will recall
that Darth Maul met his end at the hands of
Obi-Wan Kenobi during The Phantom Menace.
But fans of the animated series Clone Wars
and Rebels know that Maul survived his fall
and became a crime boss who runs the organization
known as the Shadow Collective, which in turn
runs Crimson Dawn.
Meanwhile, Solo takes place a couple of decades
after The Phantom Menace.
Maul's reveal is definitely a pausable moment,
if only for fans to try and figure out if
they're really seeing who they think they're
seeing, and work out the timeline of how the
former Sith lord turned crime boss ended up
there.
Tom Hardy's Venom was one of the weirdest
movie experiences of last year, and very much
one of the most bizarre Marvel-inspired movies
that has ever existed.
Fans can't seem to decide if it was amazing
or awful, intentionally campy or just bad
all around.
But it does feature one of the most talked-about
moments of the cinematic year: the Eddie Brock
and Venom makeout session.
Was it really between Eddie and Venom?
Was it between Eddie and his ex-girlfriend,
Anne?
All we know is, when Venom is inhabiting Anne's
body, Venom leans in for a deep and intense
full-tongue kiss.
Considering that Venom is in charge whenever
it's inhabiting someone, it certainly seems
like it was Venom who made the call to go
in deep.
Pucker up.
Through its use of sound, A Quiet Place became
one of the most innovative horror films in
years.
John Krasinski's directorial debut told the
story of a family struggling to survive after
a race of alien invaders took over the planet.
The creatures use sound to find their prey,
so being absolutely quiet is essential to
survival.
The lack of sound in much of the film makes
the suspenseful moments even more intense
and allows the tension to build.
But the most pause-worthy moment comes right
at the end, when the mother Evelyn and her
deaf daughter Regen face off against the creatures
one final time.
Regen realizes her cochlear implant
can be altered to emit a high-pitched sound
that wounds the creatures.
Upon doing so, the one hunting them opens
up its face to reveal the inner workings of
the alien beast.
“(Monster noise)”
Until that point, the creatures had stayed
mostly in the shadows, but this close look
provides the best detail of the entire movie.
It's a shot you'd definitely want to pause
just to get a good look… before Evelyn blows
its head off.
If you love Queen, then you probably loved
Bohemian Rhapsody.
Any of the musical moments in this film are
rewind-worthy, particularly the recording
session of "Bohemian Rhapsody" itself.
But the most epic scene in the entire movie
is definitely the closing sequence, which
revolves around the band's decision to perform
at Live Aid, a giant charity concert that
took place simultaneously in London and Philadelphia
in 1985.
The movie pretty much recreates Queen's entire
performance, and Rami Malek has said he considers
the concert the most important scene in the
film, telling CinemaBlend,
"It is the culmination of what the trials
and tribulations were that got them there
in the first place, and they still have something
monumental to overcome.
So I think if you look at this film, a lot
of it is about overcoming adversity and challenging
every aspect of yourself and your friends."
The 2018 Halloween is technically a direct
sequel to the 1978 original, even though there
have been six other movies between them.
This retconning of the series brings back
Jamie Lee Curtis as Laurie Strode and adds
a daughter named Karen and a granddaughter
named Allyson.
The story follows the return of Michael Myers
as he escapes from a prison transport and
heads out on a killing spree on the hunt for
Laurie.
Jamie Lee Curtis plays Laurie, now in her
60s, with a world-weariness and severe PTSD,
and she certainly has some moments of badassery
in the movie.
But the moment many fans talked about most
has more to do with the usually sweet Judy
Greer.
Though Laurie's daughter was taken from her
at an early age, Karen comes through for her
in a clutch moment.
"I'm sorry I can't do it … Gotcha."
The level of ridiculousness in The Meg reaches
pretty epic proportions, but despite being
pretty goofy, the movie is still a whole lot
of fun.
Jason Statham stars as a guy trying to capture
and kill a really big shark a megalodon, to
be precise and...that's about the entire premise.
But what it lacks in story, it makes up for
by just by going all the way.
The most epic scene in the entire movie comes
about midway through, when the gang of shark
hunters has captured the Meg and strung the
prehistoric creature up on their boat.
Or at least, they think they've captured the
Meg.
"Ahhhh, yeah, jellyfish"
The Meg took a crazy premise and made it even
crazier by making its massive villain even
bigger.
There's nothing more exciting than a good
movie gunfight, but the one-sided showdown
from Hold the Dark isn't your typical Hollywood
shootout.
This incredibly tense scene finds a group
of ill-equipped cops facing a very angry man
with a very big machine gun.
His name is Cheeon, and when the police roll
into his icy little village looking to arrest
him and his friend for murder he opens up
his second story window and unleashes hell
with an M60.
The entire scene is nothing but ice, blood,
adrenaline, and fear.
Bodies drop left and right, and the soundtrack
is filled with screaming men as Cheeon shoots
them over and over again.
It's like watching a clip from Saving Private
Ryan, and by the time the police put Cheeon
down, we need to hit the pause button so we
can slow down our heart rate and try to get
our breath back.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.